I'm trying to remember it so you did a
YouTube sketch where you're you're
walking along you've got a green hat on
but then you pull out a sto you sit down
on it and everyone's watching you and
then you just turn in St coke with
line you forgot about that yeah yeah I
forgot about that that's a good one that
is
good here we
go
hi I'm Maya kkin and I'm Donald Glover
and this is do you do you even know me
oh I like your inflection that was
better okay what happened to me the
first time I went hiking a I
accidentally peed on a cop car okay uh B
I Was Bitten on the butt by a
dog C
Paparazzi ABS AB sailed AB sailed my god
I've never I don't think he's ever said
I don't I don't think I've ever I was
like AB sailed AB sealed AB sailed down
a mountain to photograph me so I think
you kind of know it's not that one I
know not that one cuz that that would be
late in life to to start hik like I
don't know the first time you ever went
on a hike how old were
you I I I I have to be quite honest it
wasn't the first time I went on a hike
okay but it was it was a hike I'm going
to go with p PE PE with PE yeah I peed
on a I accidentally peed on a cop
car accidentally peed on a um yeah that
is wrong what was it I got bit on the
butt by dog really like a random dog a
woman I she was coming down on a bike
and she had like a dog and she came and
I was like oh and then we both and she
and the dog I think was like scared but
also like it looked like I was attacking
or something and he bit me on the butt
and I was like ow ow like I then like I
had to go to the did you did you go to
the ER yeah not to get too personal have
you still got bite marks on your PM no I
don't think so I always
like should we start they show show all
right like I don't think so I like I
have to ask my wife like I never see my
butt like I don't see I never look I
don't look at the Mir I'm like yeah look
at that sexy bite mark you know I never
see it so like I have to ask my wife if
my butt still has like a chunk missing
all right text her later whilst filming
15 how did one of the child actors
really humble me
a they kicked me in the shin and I had
to be carried off mhm B they aged me up
and thought I was 62 C they told me my
breath Wasing
nasty I'm going to say they told you
your breath was nasty why dare you
saying something no I don't think but it
just sounds like something a kid would
say so Anna and I had this I was telling
you the other day we had a code word for
if cuz we would always have a lot of
scenes where we'd be talking to each
other this close and get right in each
other's face so we'd say Evergreen um if
someone had that breath so in the middle
of a scene you just like
[Laughter]
Evergreen this is humiliating thank
you can you do a a smell test for us now
Donald just check see how the breath is
I just ate chicken pesto soup oh my God
please don't make me do please going
make me smell bro just like I'm not
going to breathe but you're going to
just get close to my
what happened when I took a date to
watch me at an improv show a she
followed me on stage and got a bigger
laugh than I did B she got so drunk
heckled us and the rest of the
performers threw her out C she
accidentally drove her car into the
building and knocked over a lamp
post B that is correct she heckled bro
it was like first of all I didn't think
like she was definitely I felt like she
was out of my league like that was like
I was new to LA and I was like this girl
is like I think she was like a model at
the store kind of and like I was like I
don't know how I got this girl to come
so she comes to the thing her and her
friend get wasted oh no wasted and my my
everybody on on my teammates are kind of
like who is this they're already who's
this girl this girl and they like hey
you you got to leave you can't be here
like you're talking throughout this like
you can't leave and she looks at me on
stage and she's like are you going to
say something and I was like I don't
know sorry to this man like I don't know
her at all like and yeah was that it you
never talked to her again oh yeah she
well she called me and she's like how
could you do this I was like you're
drunk it's fine we'll talk in the
morning never talked never talked again
how did I get revenge on a boy who dated
a friend of mine a we put raw squid on
his house B we shaved his dog and spray
painted it Orange mhm C we made up a
rumor that he was in hospital for 2
months with
diarrhea I'm going to say a I'm going to
say do you know that you know that it
feels like I know it and it just feels
more like you it just feels like a very
because I knew that at the Japanese
Market I could get raw squid and and it
was better than eggs because it it
smells bad smells bad and it specific it
feels but I like it like it feel we were
young we didn't know you know we just
yeah and you like pet so I was like the
second one doesn't really make sense we
wouldn't do that and the diarrhea I'm
like she's funnier than that she like
that's a that's she can do better than
that like s like a personal attack made
me laugh thank you so what happened
after squid gate did he come like well
we heard that his dad later like they
couldn't find the source of the smell
because you know they were small baby
squid we were just throwing them and so
it took like months to get rid of it was
pretty bad yeah which of these is not a
real character I have played W oh sorry
I but I didn't Jes right let's go home
let's I just fully look it's not to look
okay which one of these is not a real
character I have played mhm a Diet Coke
with lime B drunk baby C Marcus the
Randy
zookeeper see because I saw yeah the
answer you Marcus the the Ry what Marcus
Marcus the Randy zookeeper Randy
zookeeper Randy is really what gave it
awayand I like I if I was in a sketch
show in the UK that would work but they
don't say Randy in the in America so
like that's the only thing like that
should I just go home at this I'm saing
Randy it's all gone Diet Coke with lime
why is that I can't remember but it's
very I'm trying to remember it so you
did a YouTube sketch where you're you're
walking along you've got a green hat on
and you're walking down the street but
then you pull out a store you sit down
on it and everyone's watching you and
then you just turn in St coke with
line I forgot about that yeah yeah I
forgot about that that's a good one that
is good I do remember that we really
like that
sketch I just wear like a green hat and
like I remember yeah like and I just
turned into
it
I do remember that I was like I was like
why is that do we want to try it right
now right you walk in sit down and then
we'll
seamlessly as this holy smokes I forgot
about that sketch go what's drunk baby
drunk baby is exactly what it sounds
like Li I haven't thought about that
sketch in so long I haven't stopped
thinking about
it
okay
here we
go and
see can you believe you started a career
if I do I know I about to say my career
was like that was like one of my first
that's so
great wow these are really specific I've
got a little cre not going to
lie what do I what do I claim to have on
my person at all times a pair of my
partners worn socks mhm a photo of my
favorite South Park character m one drop
powerful bathroom
deodorizer I'm going to say a is that
true no C yes but I don't anymore it was
at one point in my life I just didn't
like it's Japanese that you just put one
drop and it's for everyone else it's for
the benefit of people after you okay now
you're like smell me smell just that I
just ate it was when I was in like high
school you know the the bathrooms that
everyone can use I just didn't want my
crush to come in after you don't all
think about that you don't care I'm like
if you love me you if you really love me
you have to deal can I just say I was
just in Japan and they have designed the
toilets now where it sucks your it sucks
the vapor and smell of your your Ence
dooo right
away so there's no smell in the bathroom
ever also I had a friend in college who
taught me like how how to as soon as it
comes out of you you flush as soon as
you like comes out of you this is so
humiliating okay complete my tweet from
2011 almost blank is just as scary as
blank both the blanks are the same oh
okay a swallowing a hot
dog B peeing in the bed C
scratching your nipples in public wa
wait wait is it almost swallowing a hot
dog is just as scary as swallowing a hot
dog is it almost peeing in the bed is
just as scary as peeing in the bed or
almost scratching your nipples in public
almost as scary as scratching your
nipples I don't know why but my
inclination is be peing that is correct
that's so interesting what do you mean
that you're all that you're scared the
anticipation of it happening is almost
as scary as happening I don't understand
this I mean maybe like like I used to
have dreams where I was peeing and like
I would always wake up and be like I
almost
peed like I almost peed like like dreams
where I'm about to pee yeah yeah I know
that yeah so like it was I feel like
that was scarier to me than like that
almost peeing is is the same fear as as
actually peeing in the bed now I'm now I
look back I'm like I was immature that
was wrong peeing in the bed is f fine
it's fine if you if you end up being
like if you I mean like yeah maybe
you're going through something but it's
fine so glad you've figured it out I
like yeah it took me a long time but
what is the craziest thing that I've
seen at a wedding a a friend of mine
lifted the mother of the groom by her
calves and started flinging her around
the room okay b a mouse had burrowed
into the wedding cake and eaten its way
out during the speeches C Joe Jonah
showed up Uninvited and instead of
singing tried roasting the bride and
groom one of these is
real yeah I'm going to say C no b
no that seems like the most weird please
explain it's my friend Aaron I won't say
his last name but he he basically he
just gets really excited he's always
split his pants every time he's at a
wedding because he wears really tight
pants and always does the splits and
gets very excited on the dance floor and
he lifted I mean I wouldn't say he was
flinging but he just you know lifted her
up and then that she was not into
it yeah yeah that sucks yeah for her
specifically the couple still together
still fine with it oh no they broke up
immediately yeah no actually
I it
was talk about this right you know mm
Omen of what to come I think they're
okay which of these is not I keep seeing
it I'm sorry it's like he's you're
holding it like this don't look it's
yellow to a silly dance over here oh my
gosh like this oh my gosh which these is
not a nickname given to my computer
which of these is not a real nickname
given to my community character Troy
Barnes a Dr stake PhD B butt soup see
the Disco
spider the steak yeah because you
cheated again I did you cheated again I
told you to read them in different ORD
so I wouldn't know but you didn't I
didn't hear you say that okay okay well
I guess now it's time for me to tell a
funny like story antidote about about
this even though it wasn't fun we got
here not having
fun I like butt soup butt soup barns I
don't I know I don't think that was an
improv I think that was written in there
it was like butt soup butt soup you know
you can't feels like mad what's been
your favorite bit of improv that you've
done on
community
um I think the funniest the the most
fun I think the most fun we had on set
was like I think there was two where
like me and Abed I think it's the first
season we're on the ground and he's
dressed as Batman and I'm dressed like
Eddie Murphy and we're like joking about
like I was like oh I would eat myself
like kind of thing that was complete
that was that part was impr but I also
always loved when we're playing Ernie
and Bert and then like we're just having
fun and then I'm like it's my cousin's
funeral today and like I have like run
out I always thought that was really we
like laugh you can tell in the shot he's
like you he's kind of smiling a little
cuz we had done it two times already and
that was I was I really like that one
cuz it was funny okay great thank you
thank you guys thank you how do you two
think you you pared did you post did you
f how do you think you fed I feel like I
cheated a little so I don't think that's
fair you feel like you cheated a little
or do we have it all on tap I guess we
have it on tape by accident though it
was by accident I'm just excited by
these facts I haven't thought about
these in a long time so thank you cook
with lime TI coke with lime classic
thank you very much
you